s'est trompé de salle va arriver
donc
le temps qu'il arrive
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons cet
après-midi nos travaux sur l'enquête
réalisée par la Cour des comptes à notre
demande sur le fondement de l'article 58
de la loge sur le scénario de
financement des collectivités
territoriales après la présentation du
rapport passer son premier président
début octobre et l'audition la semaine
dernière de représentant
d'élus du bloc communal nous
auditionnons aujourd'hui région de
France puis l'Assemblée des départements
de France
il ne s'agit pas comme la semaine
dernière d'ailleurs de présenter à
nouveau dans le détail les travaux de la
cour dont vous avez déjà pu prendre
connaissance
il commence souligné que l'une des idées
majeures qui se dégage du rapport de la
Cour et celle de concentrer la fiscalité
locale ou du moins ce qu'il en reste sur
le seul bloc communal
de nouvelles sources de financement sont
envisagées pour les autres strates de
collectivité comme un partage de l'impôt
sur le revenu avec les départements ou
encore de l'impôt sur les sociétés avec
les régions ces auditions qui sont
retransmises sur le site internet du
Sénat sont donc l'occasion de connaître
les observations des représentants des
régions et des départements sur ce sujet
ainsi que sur les autres propositions
épices ce qui sépare la cour par exemple
en matière de gouvernance des finances
locales ou de simplification de la
fiscalité transférée
notre première audition de l'après-midi
est consacrée aux régions et nous avons
donc le plaisir d'accueillir monsieur
Stéphane Perrin vice-président du
Conseil régional de Bretagne et
président délégué ça ce titre qu'il est
là je crois de la commission
administration générale des régions de
France
je remercie également le président de la
première chambre de l'accord des comptes
Monsieur Christian Charpy et la
rapporteur général de la formation
commune qui a préparé cette enquête
madame Mathilde Lignot Leloup de s'être
rendu à nouveau disponible pour
participer à nos échanges
je voudrais vous dire Monsieur Perrin
que nous avons souhaité évidemment
prendre des initiatives dans ce domaine
un domaine dans lequel on peut dire que
les îles locaux ont du mal à trouver des
convergences
c'est un peu une
et chacun on peut le comprendre
d'ailleurs
ayant d'abord en vue de préserver
son domaine
plus que finalement d'arriver à
converger la seule chose sur laquelle
nous convergerons tous c'est sur le fait
qu'il faut tout changer et la seule
chose la deuxième chose sur laquelle
nous convergeons tous c'est qu'on ne
sait pas comment le faire
et donc le Parlement a jugé utile
de poser un acte si je puis dire
un acte de courageux puisque c'est pas
un acte d'autre part directement et
plutôt l'idée de prendre un tiers de
confiance si je puis dire pour
exposer un certain nombre de points de
vue assez marqués si je peux dire avec
des hypothèses très distinctes et puis
ensuite de faire éventuellement s'il le
souhaitait si la Cour le souhaitait
faire mettre sur la table une
proposition avec des éléments en tout
cas qui nous paraissent à ce stade
suffisamment
intéressant pour que nous poursuivions
impossible cette réflexion et donc
l'objet de cette
cette audition n'est pas évidemment
ils sont supplémentaires une certaine
façon nous avons souhaité scinder les
choses pour que ça part pas dans tous
les sens combien je pas tous les sujets
et vous donner après une heure un petit
peu moins des changes entre nous pour
finalement
avoir bien comprendre le point de vue de
région de France finalement d'abord une
certaine façon par rapport à ce qui
s'est déjà passé pour les régions
puisque déjà ce on peut dire que le mode
de financement des régions a été déjà
très largement chamboulé dans les années
passées et donc le point où on allait on
se souvient tous
éventuellement des premiers cris
d'orfray je dois dire que c'est toujours
le cas puisque tout changement
amène plutôt à des inquiétudes c'est
logique
et finalement à l'impression peut-être
fausse
question du financement des régions
n'apparaît plus dans les mêmes termes en
tout cas que ceux qui ont pu être au
début des réformes lorsqu'on a notamment
enlevé la part de région etc et
finalement limiter
de manière très très vraiment très
limité
les capacités finalement d'autonomie
fiscale des régions donc avoir un point
de vue sur ce qui s'est passé comment
aujourd'hui les régions
revoient relisent cette période et puis
effectivement le directement comprendre
la position que vous pourriez avoir la
réflexion que vous avez sur les
propositions de la cour alors avant de
vous donner la parole monsieur Perrin je
vais donc céder la parole à mon corps
rapporteur que j'ai laissé le temps
ainsi de s'installer
merci monsieur le Président et
effectivement comme tu me faisablement
remarquer je me suis égaré dans la
maison je veux un problème de salle
un peu plus mais bon bref tu sais
justement c'est le début des problèmes
c'est quand tu viens je voudrais
simplement
adresser également mes remerciements
ajoutés remerciement du président non
seulement à la cour pour la qualité du
travail qu'elle nous a fourni et à vous
monsieur le Président d'être avec nous
aujourd'hui pour évoquer ces sujets
simplement je serais bref je voudrais
juste ajouter
une ou deux préoccupations à celle que
nous avons je
travaille particulièrement sur la
gouvernance des collectivités locales et
comme la souligner la cour
il a effectivement la question se pose
de la nécessité d'une d'une sorte de
nouvelle gouvernance systémique ne
serait-ce que parce que il y a un
partage d'impôts nationaux mais aussi
peut-être qu'il y a des partages à faire
entre la fiscalité d'État et la
fiscalité
des collectivités et donc il avait été
évoqué dans le rapport soit une autorité
indépendante soit une transformation du
CFL
lors de la réunion la première réunion
que nous avons eu avec vos collègues du
blog communal j'étais plutôt pour une
évolution du CFL vous nous direz si
quels sont vos préférences et
s'agissant des problématiques de
ressources qui évoquaient le président
d'instant il est vrai que tout vos
ressource n'était pas nécessairement en
adéquation avec vos compétences en fait
etc donc on se profile notamment l'idée
d'un trace d'un transfert d'impôt sur
les sociétés par exemple et alors se
poserait naturellement la question
puisque nous n'avons pas de on va dire
de gouvernance qui qui nous permettrait
de le décider ou de réfléchir à la
question comment voyez-vous la
répartition de ces impôts sur
l'association sur les sociétés est-ce
que vous voulez varier territorialiser
au niveau des régions parce que pour les
régions sont suffisamment vastes pour ce
qu'on puisse y penser ou
plutôt
répartir en fonction de critères de
développement économique du territoire
régional au plan national enfin c'est
une question supérieure qui sera
merci chers collègues j'excuse également
notre troisième Cora porteur qui est
malheureusement souffrant cette semaine
donc je m'excuse aussi auprès
des représentants de la cour en tout cas
il s'en excuse mais bon
malheureusement l'impossible nul n'est
donc je vais vous donner la parole tout
de suite pour recueillir votre d'abord
peut-être votre position sur où on en
est
l'état général la situation si je puis
dire du point de vue notamment du point
de vue des ressources
et nous faire un point là-dessus et
deuxième partie si vous le voulez bien
comment vous recevez ces propositions
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je lui également les
représentants de la Cour des comptes
vous avez utilisé monsieur le Président
le mot tiers de confiance
et je veux dire qu'on a un dialogue
fréquent avec la cour j'étais encore
auditionné par la Cour lundi
et je crois que le rôle de la Cour je
l'ai dit à la cour et je le dis devant
vous et je le dis publiquement le rôle
de la Cour dans ces exercices
où il faut parfois commencer par
objectiver une situation de départ et
avoir un accord sur les situations de
départ me paraît essentiel nous paraît
essentiel et donc
la mobilisation de la disposition de la
Golf que vous avez évoquée me paraît
tout à fait opportunes et j'espère à
titre personnel qu'elle fera un peu
école et que le rôle de la Cour en tant
que tiers de confiance se réveille
identifié je le dis voilà sans c'est pas
de la flagornerie mais c'est vrai que
dans ces périodes où comme vous l'avez
dit il faut tout changer
il faut au moins se mettre d'accord sur
les termes du débat je ne sais pas si
nous arriverons à nous mettre d'accord
sur le résultat mais j'ai observé dans
la période récente parlant de la
situation financière des régions par
exemple que nous avions eu parfois des
difficultés à
à être d'accord sur les constats de
départ et que c'est la cour qui
finalement a été le juge de paix dans
cette affaire ce qui est essentiel quand
on part ensuite dans des discussions en
projet de loi de finance ou en loi de
finances rectificative donc je voudrais
d'abord saluer le rôle de la Cour et
saluer cette initiative
vous dire assez directement que
votre initiative est d'autant plus
la bienvenue que le modèle de
financement des régions est appelée à
mourir à court terme
et là la crise que nous connaissons et
l'inflation que nous connaissons a été
un puissant accélérateur
de cette marche vers la mort du système
de recettes des régions pourquoi
parce que pour une bonne part nous
recettes sont assis sur la fiscalité
liée à l'automobile
par de TICPE et puis taxe sur la carte
grise qui est notre dernier levier
fiscal à hauteur 10% des recettes des
régions donc c'est un tout petit levier
fiscal
alors pourquoi ce système est mort alors
déjà il était absurde puisque la
compétence une des compétences majeures
des régions aujourd'hui sont sur les
mobilités
les mobilités collectives via le
ferroviaire le TER via le transport
intérieur bas et que par hypothèse plus
nous allons développer le transport
collectif moins nous allons
susciter de besoins en recours aux
véhicules automobiles et au carburant et
donc plus nous allons mener des
politiques vertueuses moins nous allons
avoir de recettes
et quand je dis que la crise a été
impuissante accélérateur c'est qu'on
assiste aujourd'hui et on l'a corrigé
dans nos décisions modificatives de fin
d'exercice 22 et on le voit lorsque on
est dans la construction des budgets
pour l'année 2023 nous allons avoir des
diminutions très fortes de produits
taxes sur la carte grise
lié au fait que le marché de
l'automobile s'effondre en ce moment
alors il y a plusieurs facteurs le coût
des véhicules augmente
les aides qui étaient versées pour
l'aide à l'achat aux véhicules s'arrête
donc c'est un secteur qui était je veux
pas dire sous fort perfusion d'argent
public mais enfin qui quand même était
fortement mobilisateur de crédit public
et donc tout ça que ce soit sur le
véhicule neuf et par effet de bord sur
le véhicule d'occasion fait qu'il y a
beaucoup moins de transactions et donc
beaucoup de pertes de recettes et quand
en plus on vous annonce la fin du
véhicule thermique à l'horizon 2035
ambition européenne c'est une assiette
qui va donc fondre puis disparaître
complètement
et donc quelques régions dont la mienne
d'ailleurs vont relever le taux de la
taxe sur la carte grise cette année pour
compenser les effets d'inflation qu'on
connaît mais c'est une fuite en avant
puisque plus l'assiette va fondre plus
nous allons augmenter le taux mais de
toute façon on sait très bien que ça
nous mènera nulle part donc le modèle de
recette il est appelé à mourir et donc
il va falloir en changer et là quand je
dis en changer pour les régions c'est
pas un moyen terme c'est à très court
terme sans quoi nous serons dans
l'incapacité de financer les politiques
publiques que ce soit en fonctionnement
ou en investissement
alors vous m'avez appelé monsieur le
Président à faire un retour sur le passé
il se trouve que j'ai vécu la la bascule
de la DGF à la
TVA pour les régions nous sommes
désormais attributeurs de la TVA alors
je ne vais pas faire ici me faire ici
ne représentant de la nostalgie du temps
de la DGF qui était une recette qui
avait réussi qui diminuait qui avait
diminué beaucoup
et dans le cadre de la contribution
redressement des finances publiques à
l'époque et donc la bascule vers la TVA
nous a offert à un bol d'air frais dans
la mesure où évidemment la dynamique de
que représente la TVA et sans commune
mesure avec les perspectives que nous
pouvions avoir au titre de l'évolution
de la DGF
et pour être tout à fait clair si nous
arrivons à assumer pour 2022 les
puissants
surcoulient à l'inflation
facture de nos lycées énergies dans nos
lycées factures d'électricité sur les
mobilités ou factures de carburant pour
les mobilités par car c'est parce que
nous avons en 2022 une bonne dynamique
de TVA donc je le dis de manière très
claire cette bascule-là a été la
bienvenue c'est pas une bascule qui nous
redonne de l'autonomie fiscale mais en
tout cas en termes de dynamique c'est
sans commune mesure mais aujourd'hui
il faut bien dire qu'elle est annulée
par ce que je décrivais sur la fiscalité
sur l'automobile qui décroît et qui
encore une fois est appelé à diminuer et
pour l'année 2023 nous anticipons une
dégradation de l'épargne des régions
parce que précisément la dynamique de
TVA ne sera plus là ou en tout cas ne
sera pas du niveau de 2022 et des encore
moins des années précéd
et dans le même temps nous aurons
toujours cette attrition des recettes
sur la fiscalité automobile donc
évidemment
les plus c'est les moins font qu'on
anticipe plutôt une dégradation du solde
malgré une TVA qui estimée je crois
autour de 5 points cette année 5,3 on
dit alors je peux vous donner si je
malgré ce point il y aura une
dégradation
je m'en suis ouvert auprès de la Cour
pas plus tard que lundi et on pourra
vous redonner les chiffres en 2023 on
anticipe un surcoulié à l'inflation
alors en additionnant les lycées TER
transports et ma salarial puisqu'on en
effet point d'indice en année pleine à
hauteur de 977 millions d'euros pour
l'ensemble des régions et un surplus de
recettes à hauteur de
786 millions d'euros que nous calculons
pour l'instant uniquement sur le surplus
de TVA puisque nous n'avons nous partons
d'une hypothèse de stabilité sur la
carte grise et les certificats
d'immatriculation alors qu'on aura
vraisemblablement une baisse donc au
total 977 millions de hausses de charges
versus
766 millions de hausse de recettes
forcément le sol des négatifs de 200
millions en année 2022 la situation
était inverse puisqu'on avait une très
bonne dynamique de TVA donc on avait
plus d'un milliardente dynamique de
recettes versus
957 millions de de surcoût en dépense et
donc là le sol des globalement positif
même si et ça la cour l'avait établie
les régions étaient le seul niveau de
collectivité à ne pas avoir retrouvé
leur niveau d'épargne d'avant la crise
covid puisque c'est aussi un élément
qu'il faut que porter à votre
connaissance et que la Cour avait
établi et c'est en cela que je disais
que la Cour avait le seul rôle de tiers
de confiance c'est qu'il y a une
dégradation de la capacité d'épargne
liée à la crise covid et que nous
n'avons pas retrouvé le niveau excenté
vraisemblablement on peut on peut le
dire parce que c'est le niveau de
collectivité qui a été le moins
accompagné au cours de cette crise covid
hormis les 600 millions d'euros de
soutien à l'investissement mais qu'on
doit mettre en regard des deux milliards
sur la même période de hausse de
l'investissement des régions donc vous
voyez que c'est une contribution
peut-être conséquente mais en tout cas
en proportion pas majoritaire dans
l'effort des investissements des régions
donc c'est plutôt les politiques
volontaristes des personnes qui ont
provoqué cette hausse l'investissement
mais dans le même temps on a bien une
dégradation de ce niveau de l'EHPAD et
donc si je reprends le fil de ce que je
vous disais au départ c'est-à-dire d'un
modèle de recette qui paraît
dépérir au fil de détente nous risquons
d'avoir une difficulté à terme alors il
se traduira évidemment pas par un
surendettement des régions mais par une
diminution de l'investissement et à un
moment où nous n'avons pas encore ouvert
les chapitres mobilité des CPER par
exemple et où on sait que les besoins en
la matière sont extraordinairement
importants donc
le l'analyse que l'on peut faire de la
période passée c'est d'une part cette
satisfaction d'avoir cette recette de
TVA mais d'autre part d'avoir un modèle
de recette qui quand même au global ne
nous permet pas d'assumer d'une part en
tendance longue on va dire les
politiques publiques et avec ce coût
d'accélérateur que l'on connaît de lier
à l'inflation et liée à la crise à crise
sur le autonomie fiscal et
j'y reviendrai lorsque je réagirai aux
propositions de la cour c'est vrai que
nous en avons nous n'en avons quasiment
plus nous sommes nous inaugurons
finalement où nous avons inauguré en ce
modèle qui est aujourd'hui largement
répandue qui est une affectation de part
d'impôts national
alors ça ouvre des questions qui
dépassent largement ma condition de des
livres régionales mais qui refrochent
pour les représentants de la nation que
vous êtes interroge bon d'une part il y
a le fait que la TVA est un impôt qui a
aussi ses avantages et ses inconvénients
en termes de défaire régressif ou
dégressif mais surtout ce qui interroge
c'est le fait que l'État est aujourd'hui
attributaire d'une part minoritaire du
produit de la TVA et que la
généralisation de ce système où l'état
où les collectivités sont affectateurs
d'une part d'impôt national interroge
en sens inverse sur la capacité corps à
l'état à financer ses propres politiques
publiques
alors que la TVA est l'impôt dont on
sait qu'il a le rendement le plus élevé
enfin des rendements les plus élevés
et ça se poser une difficulté qui est
que mais ça c'est des choix de politique
fiscales qu'on voit bien que on cherche
un peu à faire disparaître l'impôt on a
beaucoup recours aux impôts indirects
je vais donc dit à d'affectation
d'impôts nationales donc on réduit aussi
les assiettes il y a des choix
politiques qui sont fermes on enlève la
CVAE pour ne plus avoir d'impôt sur la
production
c'est un choix peu importe ce qu'on en
pense mais le constat au global c'est ce
système qui consiste à affecter aux
collectivités une part d'improvationales
et ce qui sera tenable dans le temps
parce que l'État lui aussi a besoin de
financer ses politiques publiques donc
mon interrogation elle est celle-là je
ne peux pas en dire beaucoup plus encore
une fois c'est des choix qui
appartiennent au par le pont puisque
c'est lui qui est la décisionnaire en
dernier ressort au loi de finances mais
c'est une vraie question
donc on va dire à l'échelon nationale
comme ça je laisse ouvert le je laisse
ouvert les conclusions de ce point de
vue en tout cas voilà c'est des choses
qu'il faut avoir à l'esprit aussi quand
on fait des choix de scénario de
financement parce que on voit bien qu'en
réduisant les assiettes que l'on
souhaite imposer en distribuant les les
produits d'impôts qui restent entre
plusieurs
bénéficiaires ou plus de bénéficiaires
alors qu'on est à un moment où on le
voit bien la demande
d'invest investissement ou même sur des
compétences régaliennes de l'État est
très forte tout ça peut interroger donc
je suis de ce point de vue là
interrogatif et je encore une fois c'est
des choses qui appartiennent avant tout
représentant de la nation mais dont nous
serons finalement les les supporteront
les effets en dernier ressort alors
partant de là la question effectivement
c'est posée du vers quel modèle
devons-nous aller
alors la proposition que fait la cour
a globalement reçu la sentiment de
région de France et la présidente d'Elga
a eu l'occasion de le dire pourquoi
parce que l'impôt sur les sociétés en
tout cas est plus en lien avec
nos compétences que les recettes que
nous pouvions avoir jusqu'à maintenant
dans la complexité d'ailleurs qui est
évoquée par la Cour et la faible
lisibilité
je tiens à souligner que il y a des
bizarris quand des parts de tcpe sont là
pour compenser des dépenses qui sont
relatives à l'apprentissage enfin tout
ça devient très tortueux on a une espèce
de sédimentation au fur et à mesure des
réformes qui fait que on a un panier de
recettes qui devient complètement
illisible pour les citoyens mais même
parfois pour les élus donc effectivement
il est temps de probablement de passer à
autre chose aussi pour des raisons
démocratiques et de lisibilité pour les
pour
et donc l'affectation d'une part d'impôt
sur les sociétés paraît être une
solution qui en tout cas est en ligne
avec nos compétences elle appelle
probablement
de précision
la première c'est que nous serions dans
un modèle TVA plus impôt sur les
sociétés dans un mécanisme un système de
recettes qui est intégralement lié à la
conjoncture économique
ce qui veut dire que les périodes de
retournement de cycle économique nous
aurions une dépression de l'ensemble de
nos recettes puisque nous n'avons pas ce
qu'on pourrait qualifier des impositions
de la fiscalité de stock donc nous
sommes totalement
dépendants du cycle économique alors
qu'en face les régions aujourd'hui des
compétences
qui sont des compétences
de services à la population sur les
mobilités sur la formation
professionnelle sur les lycées qui ne
sont pas indépendantes du cycle
économique et donc la question c'est
comment on assure on va dire le
financement des politiques en période
creuse en période de vache maigre
une des demandes qui avait formulé la
présidente Delga qui n'a pour l'instant
pas été suivi en loi de finance et qui
paraîtrait d'autant plus nécessaire dans
un nouveau modèle tel que celui qui est
proposé par la Cour c'est d'avoir la
capacité à minima de mise en réserve de
la dynamique comme ça a été fait pour
les départements dans le cas de la mise
en réserve de l'Europe mutation et de ce
que j'ai compris les départements ont
activement mobilisés ce système là ils
savent bien que nos collègues élus des
départements que ils sont dépendants du
marché de l'immobilier et que en face
ils ont des politiques pérennes à
financer que ce soit la pas le RSA et
donc c'est un mécanisme que je
qualifierais de prudentiel qui paraît
absolument nécessaire il la présidente
Delga a eu l'occasion de le demander
déjà
dans un dans un modèle TVA + is ça
paraît indispensable au moins pour
préserver les capacités d'intervention
en période de crise et puis vous avez
posé la question monsieur le rapporteur
de la codécision de la
territorialisation
alors il est clair que les régions
n'auraient pas dans ce modèle
d'autonomie fiscale à tout le moins ce
que les régions avaient exprimé comme
demande dans leur livre blanc c'est un
de la codécision
et là ça pose effectivement la question
que vous avez posé monsieur le
rapporteur de la gouvernance alors
c'est vrai que l'organisation
territoriale d'un état et son
organisation fiscale sont deux choses
distinctes j'ai l'habitude de citer
l'exemple de nos collègues de nos
voisins allemands un État fédéral mais
où les l'Ender n'ont pas forcément
d'autonomie mais par contre où ils sont
dans un dialogue avec l'État fédéral sur
l'attribution des parts d'impôts
nationaux donc il faudrait un minima
créer les conditions de ce dialogue là
qui il faut bien dire n'existe pas
aujourd'hui
j'ai siégé en CFL lors de la
présentation du PLF vous avez la réunion
du Conseil des ministres le matin les
ministres qui viennent l'après-midi une
heure
qui vous présente les choses on a peu de
temps pour poser des questions et fin de
l'histoire et après sa vie sa vie
parlementaire et donc forcément les
espaces de discussion aujourd'hui
n'existent absolument pas et donc il
faut un minima que nous puissions avoir
un espace d'échange et de codécision
dans un format qu'il faut définir
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas vous dire
précisément qu'elle peut être lequel il
peut être je parle en termes de
Procédure
il y avait eu pendant la le processus de
révision constitutionnel qui avait été
engagée
l'idée d'une loi de financement des
collectivités territoriales alors j'en
avais parlé avec votre collègue
Françoise Gatel qui m'avait expliqué
que je fréquente beaucoup par ailleurs
mais qui va avec expliquer que
effectivement
c'était pas forcément la solution
idoine parce qu'elle pouvait être
piégieuse y compris pour les
collectivités mais il faut en tout cas
créer cet espace là ça peut être
effectivement un CFL rénové alors la
difficulté c'est que il faut regarder
avec précision la composition du CFL
parce que si les collectivités ils sont
minoritaires c'est un exercice qui va
assez rapidement s'avérer 20 et
desceptif et donc si le CFL peut être ce
lieu et cet espace de discussion il
faudra en tout cas que dans l'exercice
en termes de composition et de
procédures on s'assure que les
collectivités n'y soient pas
minoritaires ce serait quand même une
difficulté et ça ne créait pas la
confiance que nous recherchons
ça peut être un mécanisme de
contractualisation alors évidemment pas
sur le modèle du chaos qui n'était pas
un contrat
encore moins sur le modèle qui nous
avait été proposé qui est une norme de
dépenses de fonctionnement
mais même sans aucun effort même
superficiel de contractualisation par
contre il y a une contractualisation
globale qui intègre le volet financier
mais qui en intègre d'autres sur des
expérimentations sur la différenciation
serait un exercice qui serait beaucoup
plus riche
est-ce que l'État y est prêt je ne sais
pas parfois des doutes
je comprends que le gouvernement soit
dans l'obligation de crédibiliser une
trajectoire pour les finances publiques
et nous l'entendons parfaitement et donc
il y ait quelque part un acte qui
permette de crédibiliser cette
trajectoire sur les finances publiques
et le bienvenu je dis souvent que nous
sommes tous en même bateau le jour la
note de l'État est dégradée la note des
régions sera mécaniquement dégradé
derrière donc nous sommes tous embarqués
dans le même bateau donc nous n'avons
pas intérêt à jouer à un niveau contre
un autre
mais si nous pouvons avoir un exercice
de contractualisation un peu plus riche
et un peu plus dense que celui-ci que
nous avons vécu par le passé
d'autant plus que lorsque je fais à
nouveau une rétrospective vers un retour
un regard vers le passé monsieur le
Président il y a des régions qui ont
signé le contrat car d'autres qui ne
l'ont pas signé
ça n'a eu aucun effet aucune conséquence
toutes les régions étaient dans les
clous pour quelle raison parce que c'est
pas une injonction de l'État qui dicte
la manière dont nous gérons les
collectivités c'est pas une trajectoire
dictée qui le fait
je prends l'exemple de ma région la
capacité des endettements je sais que en
aucun cas ne peut excéder huit ans
parce que si elle excès de 8 ans j'ai
des emprunts contractés auprès de
l'abbaye je leur donnerai des intérêts
supplémentaires
donc
nous on a signé un contrat mais on en
aurait pas signé serait exactement
pareil et les régions qui n'ont pas
signé le Cahors on respectait totalement
les clous qui étaient fixés dans la loi
donc on voit bien que l'exercice ou
l'utilité de l'exercice
est très faible si ce n'est montrait une
forme de marque de défiance vis-à-vis
des collectivités surtout quand on sait
que c'est pas les collectivités et en
tout cas pas les régions qui contribuent
dans le solde global
des contes de la nation
au déficit et à l'endettement donc je
pense que c'était inutilement avec sa
toile et qu'on aurait des exercices
beaucoup plus riches à faire qui peuvent
intégrer les sujets que j'ai évoqués si
nous décidons demain de mettre en
réserve une partie de TVA ou de dixième
x ça peut faire partie d'un élément de
contractualisation mais ça veut dire
aussi qu'il faut que l'État soutient y
compris localement pour piloter ce genre
de décision
et je veux partager ici avec vous je me
permets de le faire publiquement je les
fais dans la session du Conseil régional
au siège j'ai été assez choqué
finalement par le propos du ministre du
Budget qui est en séance du CFN nous dit
plus de Cahors plus de micro management
et moi ça m'a choqué parce que
micromanagement c'était quoi c'était une
présidente ou un président de région qui
discute avec un préfet
pour moi ça s'appelle la République ça
s'appelle pas du micro management et
donc si nous avons capacité à
contractualiser avec un état déconcentré
qui est bien outillé y compris en termes
de lecture des des finances locales
alors est-ce que c'est les Chambres
régionales est-ce que c'est d'autres
corps je n'en sais rien mais ça nous
sera beaucoup plus utile quant à la
territorialisation pour terminer par là
c'est un vieux débat alors si nous
territorialisation si nous
territorialisons nous allons devoir
penser en même temps péréquation
bon le modèle de recette d'aujourd'hui
des régions rend moins nécessaire même
si nous l'avons fait
le travail sur la péréquation puisque
parisotes vous êtes dans un système
national avec une évolution nationale et
donc
vous ne créez pas de distorsion en tout
cas de distorsion nouvelle parfois on
traîne des distorsions passées qui ne
sont jamais corrigées mais par contre on
ne crée pas de distorsion nouvelle si
nos territorialisons effectivement il
faut travailler sur la péréquation et
puis si nos territorialisons il faut
faire très attention parce qu'on a eu le
précédent de la CVAE c'est parfois très
compliqué vous avez des effets de siège
et moi j'avais des collègues qui
m'expliquaient que y compris en
intercommunalité ils voyaient du
développement économique se faire sur
leur territoire mais il n'en voyait pas
la traduction dans leur compte en ces
verbes
donc il va falloir aussi travailler si
la décidot est prise de territorialisée
sur un à une lecture une grille de
lecture très efficace sur cette
territorialisation et sur les critères
pour ne pas avoir des effets de siège
dont on connaît un peu les résultats
c'est-à-dire que on concentre les choses
sur quelques pôles très forts
d'attractivité
au détriment d'autres territoires et ça
crée une là une difficulté
supplémentaire que ne corrige pas une
paire équation ou très imparfaitement
puisque là c'est le système au départ
qui qui présente un défaut de conception
voilà je veux pas être plus long
monsieur le Président sur les constats
mais encore une fois vous redire en tout
cas pour région de France que
votre travail le travail que vous avez
initié et d'autant plus opportun que je
pense que
pour vous dire les choses clairement il
faudra que les choses évoluent dès le
prochain PLF pour les régions
et surtout au regard d'un point que je
n'ai pas évoqué qui est trop peu évoqué
qui est le financement de la compétence
mobilité qui en soit est un sujet
qui mérite un travail alors là connecté
au sujet lié à la loi l'homme et à la
coordination et à l'articulation entre
les autorités organisatrices de mobilité
je ne sais pas alors je mets de côté le
cas il de France qui est sur un modèle
d'organisation évidemment tout à fait
différent mais ce sujet du financement
de la compétence monétique je parle bien
en fonctionnement il y a des sujets
d'investissement de régénération du
réseau ferroviaire que vous connaissez
très bien donc je sais que il en est
souvent question au Sénat mais sur le
fonctionnement de la compétence mobilité
il y a un vrai sujet nos concitoyens ne
comprennent pas ou ne comprendrez pas
qu'on fonctionne dans un paysage
fractionné avec des autorités de
mobilité qui sont chacune dans leur
périmètre chacune avec leurs recettes
alors qu'il se déplace
d'un auteur du territoire d'une autorité
de mobilité à une autre parce que il
n'habite pas là où il travaille et que
les temps de déplacement et sont sont
plus longs et et les besoins de
déplacement sont plus long donc il y a
un vrai sujet là qui doit devoir être
expertisé en plus du travail qui est
conduit et qui mérite en soi une
réflexion
poussée et là aussi urgentes parce que
les choses évoluent très vite voilà
monsieur le Président pour mes
observations merci et puis merci d'avoir
fait une préparation si je puis dire sur
le thème que vous connaissez bien
entendu mais enfin être arrivé avec un
propos comment dire clair sur voilà sur
des sujets qui sont pas toujours qui ne
sont pas toujours
donc en tout cas nous avons parfaitement
compris votre votre exposé
alors je vais peut-être donner la parole
à Stéphane sottael qui a demandé
alors si vous le voulez bien mes chers
collègues nous avons eu déjà deux
sessions nous en aurons une quatrième
tout à l'heure donc restez sur le thème
région si vous le voulez bien ne pas
réinterroger la course sur des sur des
sujets qui ont déjà été abordés etc mais
vraiment rester centré sur la question
régionale
merci monsieur le Président je dis ça
parce que je donne la parole un ancien
directeur de département
[Rires]
des régions et je remercie l'intervenant
représentant des régions de France et de
la région Bretagne pour ses propos à la
fois la clarté la construction et pour
l'essentiel de l'analyse que je que je
partage du coup je voulais juste revenir
sur deux points ou poser deux questions
d'une part par rapport à un nouveau
panier d'impôts ou de ressources à
partir d'un pot nationaux que serait TVA
plus is comme ça a été évoqué pour aller
vite je voulais avoir votre avis sur la
question d'une part
de
taux d'impôts régionalisé est-ce que on
pourrait imaginer ou est-ce que dans
votre votre point de vue une part
d'iesse qui serait territorialisée une
part de to dièse qui régionalisée aurait
un intérêt un sens et qu'elle serait
votre votre approche de ce point-là et
le deuxième point sur la
contractualisation effectivement je
partage l'idée d'une contractualisation
beaucoup plus large et la question des
mobilités se posent à la fois sur
l'investissement parce que la
contribution aujourd'hui des régions au
CPER elle dépend directement de leur
capacité d'autofinancement et donc je
voulais vous interroger sur ce point là
sur le lien entre cette capacité et les
ressources des régions et
compléter par votre préoccupation sur le
fonctionnement sur
les aways et vous dire effectivement
qu'au niveau de la commission des
finances du Sénat nous avons décidé de
conduire une mission d'information sur
cette question là qui nous semble
effectivement particulièrement
prégnantes et donc je ne doute pas qu'on
puisse revenir sur cette question
particulière dans le cadre de cette
mission
un essai en espérant que le président
que j'ai été concis et concentré sur le
sujet parfait
y a-t-il oui Michel Cannet
vice-président de la Région Bretagne qui
s'est porté la bonne parole des régions
de France il a fait avec qualité dans
son exposé je voulais lui demander si
dans les réflexions qui sont conduites à
région de France ont pu être déjà
identifié des ressources fiscales qui
permettrait de d'accroître l'autonomie
dite financière ou fiscale des
collectivités puisque à mon avis ça doit
être un objectif à poursuivre les
collectivités territoriales quelle
qu'elle soit ne peuvent se contenter
d'être des redistributrices de dotation
d'état ou voire même d'impôts nationaux
il faut aussi que qu'il y ait la
responsabilité
financière et fiscale des élus qui
soient mises en avant et donc il paraît
être paraîtrait intéressant à cet égard
que en plus identifier un mode de
financement qui permettent aussi
d'engager la responsabilité des élus qui
permettent d'assurer véritablement
l'autonomie financière de nos
collectivités
merci Michel
Marc Lamini
et merci beaucoup je le président puis
nous nos collègues rapporteurs Charles
Denis puis merci à la cour ainsi que
Monsieur le vice-président représentant
président des régions de France pour vos
propos pour qu'on le mérite aussi de
nous éclairer alors concernant les
compétences des régions elles sont quand
même nombreuses vous l'avez vouloir vous
l'avez rappelé sur les sur les
compétences c'est aussi une
collectivités territoriales qui un
niveau qui investit aussi beaucoup alors
concernant bon un sujet qui me qui me
gérait m'anime toujours un petit peu
c'est le l'intervention des régions dans
les domaines des TER fr/roviaires en
particulier
donc il y a eu quand même beaucoup
d'efforts des
des collectivités régionales concernant
le matériel déjà le matériel de
l'ensemble des terres acquisition
construction
matérielle neuf etc plus aussi sur les
infrastructures de de réseau et je
rejoins aussi le travail qui a fait mon
voisin Stéphane sauterelle et Hervé
Moret concernant je dirais
la SNCF elle ferroviaire
alors moi ma question un petit peu
concernant ces investissements en la
matière et de l'autre côté l'aspect
l'aspect
recette puisque vous l'avez indiqué le
l'autonomie financière des régions
diminuent
quel pourrait être d'après vous sur le
président les les hormis bon la TVA
liesse ou autre
quel moyen financier pourrait être
envisager c'est un petit peu ma question
est-ce que maintenant les grandes
régions les grandes régions
est-ce que c'est un plus ou c'est j'irai
moins bien qu'avant ou c'était des
régions j'irai avec beaucoup moins de de
département si on peut dire merci
Marc
je vais peut-être donner la parole si
vous le voulez bien à la cour pour avoir
peut-être une réaction aussi tout en
prenant nos questions mais nos questions
s'adressaient beaucoup à notre invité
mais avoir un premier premier éclairage
de réponse par rapport à la fois
peut-être que je t'ai proposé mais
surtout par rapport à la position de du
vice-président merci beaucoup mais
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs sénateurs d'abord je remercie
Monsieur Perrin qui qui exprime ici ce
qu'il a également exprimé dans des
auditions
comme nous avons fait ce rapport et et
la réponse qui a fait madame Delga donc
je voulais dire peut-être trois choses
pour commencer la première c'est que
nous avons été très conscients des
difficultés financières à terme que
rencontrerait les régions du fait de sa
fiscalité assise sur l'île de grabure et
sur les voitures et donc c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles nous avons sur
ce sujet comme sur un autre que pas tout
à l'heure je pensais que le département
considéré que les impôts qui allait
vocation à se réduire ou être très
fluctuant il était préférable que l'État
les prennent en charge plutôt que de
dépasser directement aux qualités
locales parce que l'État a une capacité
de réaction d'emprunt
il utilise assez largement ça sa
capacité d'emprunt il faut le
reconnaître mais il a une capacité à
réagir peut-être plus forte que les
collectivités locales c'est pour ça
qu'on avait tout à fait prévu que la
TICPE et les certificats-unis avaient
plutôt vocation à remonter au niveau
national
ça c'est le premier point sur le second
point je suis assez content que le
président Perrin dise que justement
l'impôt national partagé c'est pas la
bonne élimination de l'Abomination ça
peut être s'agissait en tout cas de la
TVA un impôt relativement dynamique
alors c'est vrai que notre proposition
on met à côté de la TVA un autre apôt
économique qui est liesse autant la TVA
c'est vrai
rarement parce que la consommation en
France ne baisse pas
même je crois qu'en
2009 je suis même pas certain que la TVA
est considérablement WC ou très
vaguement très faiblement et en tout cas
sur la dernière crise elle n'a pas été
affectée significativement donc c'est un
impôt qui est quand même très résilient
au crise parce qu'il repose sur une
consommation qu'elle-même est très
résiliente parce qu'elle s'appuie sur
les revenus des ménages qui sont très
résilients parce que soutenus donc voilà
donc il y a pas de grosses difficultés
c'est plus compliqué je reconnaissais
ici sur le dièse qui a elle est capable
de connaître des
des fluctures plus significatives donc
je trouve qu'effectivement il faut
réfléchir à ce qui évoquer le président
perra c'est-à-dire des mécanismes de
mise en réserve alors c'est un peu
contraires au principe généraux mais je
pense qu'il y a des sujets sur lesquels
il faut savoir avancer celui-ci en est
un ensuite il y a la question sur l'IS
de la territorialisation alors je suis
très
très attentif aux effets que vous avez
des effets de siège si on territorialise
complètement l'impôt sur les sociétés
objectivement on va favoriser la région
Île-de-France la région Rhône-Alpes
quelques-unes en plus mais pas
consciemment et d'autres seront quand
même très très pénalisés et donc
effectivement on va rentrer dans le
mécanisme de de péréquation qui sont
très lourds alors en même temps je suis
conscient que c'est difficile
d'inciter une région à fabriser des
plans économiques et de l'entir aucun
profit sur ses ressources donc nous ce
que nous avions imaginé ces deux
hypothèses la première qui est assez
simple sur lequel on peut réfléchir
c'est dire trouvons des modes de
répartition qui soit incitatifs à la
création d'entreprise donc on se dit par
exemple est-ce qu'on peut pas imaginer
qu'il y a une part de cette ise qui soit
répartie en fonction du nombre
d'entreprises créées ou de
l'augmentation du nom de prescrit bon on
peut trouver quelques critères qui
permettent de favoriser ça l'autre sujet
sur lequel les amis réfléchissez l'idée
d'un taux complémentaire
qui peut se poser pour l'IS qui peut se
poser on le verra avec le département
pour les départements aussi
la difficulté me semble-t-il c'est que
les acteurs économiques sont quand même
très mobiles voilà et s'ils do dièse en
région Bretagne est élevé et pourront
peut-être se dire ben mettons le siège
plutôt en Pays de Loire donc voilà il y
a quand même un risque qui n'est pas
complètement à négliger le troisième
point sur lequel je voudrais assister
c'est sur la question de l'instance de
concertation et de dialogue
dans notre esprit
c'est notamment pour veiller à ce que
pardonnez-moi l'État joue correctement
la règle du jeu
et si on se met à partager des impôts
nationaux on a le risque que des
décisions comme les Thalès a pris sur la
CVE ont pris les mêmes soldiers sont
décidés
si on dit on donne une part d'iesse à
aux régions et quelle est la décision
qui affectent l'IS ça affecte aussi les
régions donc moi mon idée c'est que
l'instance de concertation doit veiller
à ce que les efforts ou les
compensations soient correctement
partagées pour pas qu'il y ait un jeu de
dupe donc c'est vrai pour pour la
compensation des baisses d'impôts c'est
vrai pour veiller à un outil de aux
éventuels péréquations c'est vrai pour
veiller à l'égalité de répartition des
impôts des dotations entre collectivités
en fonction de leurs besoins objectifs
voilà pour moi c'est c'est ça qui est
essentiel alors si le CFL est capable de
le faire pourquoi pas j'ai bien entendu
ce qu'elle dit présent Perrin le CFL
n'est pas complètement représentatif des
différents niveaux de collectivité et
ensuite son rôle aujourd'hui est un peu
pénalisé par enfin son avenir de maître
pénalisé par le rôle qu'elle a
aujourd'hui ce que vous avez dit est
très clair c'est plutôt une chambre
d'enregistrement et de récrimination il
y a un peu de travail aussi enfin c'est
pas forcément là où le lieu se voilà
donc je pense qu'il est peut-être
préférable on avait des hypothèses mais
de réfléchir à quelque chose qui donne
plus de poids
je sais que le Sénat est souvent
réticent les gars des hautes autorités
j'ai bien entendu
je note par exemple le Haut Conseil des
finances publiques quand il dit qu'il y
a un sujet sur les prévisions de
recettes fiscales ou sur la prison c'est
entendu jusqu'au plus haut niveau
puisque le Conseil consuel en prend acte
voilà et donc je dis voilà une autorité
sinon de poids pour dire attention la
loi de finance ne respecte pas les
principes de prévisibilité voilà c'est
c'est pas dans un impact sur l'avenir
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire sur la
contractualisation pour terminer bon je
note votre vos jugements sur le les
contrats de Cahors c'était pas forcément
la
panacée
ce que je constate c'est qu'il y a
beaucoup de contractuations qui se
superposent aujourd'hui entre ce qui est
fait au niveau des régions ce qui est
fait au niveau des contrats de
territoires et de résilience il y a un
moment on s'y perd et deuxièmement et là
vous avez parfaitement raison je pense
qu'il faut qu'on ait au niveau des
territoires de la République dans le
service des concentrés suffisamment de
capacité à gérer ses contrats et c'est
aujourd'hui extrêmement lourd
merci de votre position peut-être
quelques points de remarque monsieur le
président
si je suis le président alors en
réaction
aux questions des sénateurs et puis dans
le prolongement des de ce que vient le
président Charpy et que je partage
largement alors sur la question par
d'impôts régionalisé
pour être très clair il n'y a pas de
consensus sur
l'autonomie fiscale
entre les présidents de région je vais
être transparent être très clair
si vous me demandez mon avis
personnel mais avec mon tropisme breton
et mes travers bretons je vous dirai oui
pour les raisons qui a évoqué le
sénateur qui avait fait c'est à dire que
effectivement moi j'ai tendance à
considérer que l'élu est doit être
responsable sur les dépenses et sur les
recettes et je constate d'ailleurs que
c'est quelque chose qu'on dénira jamais
au maire
en tout cas
donc c'est mais je dois bien reconnaître
que c'est pas quelque chose qui est
partagé par l'ensemble des présidents de
région
nous avions commis en Bretagne un
rapport sur la fiscalité locale nous
avions fait un panorama des
européens enfin en tout cas quelques
échantillons il y a des pays l'Italie
par exemple où il y a une part
régionalisée d'impôt sur leurs revenus
donc ça existe bon
en toute état de cause ça pose les
questions que le président Charpy a
évoqué c'est-à-dire que évidemment
ça peut générer de la concurrence
fiscale ça génère des effets
anti-péréquateur qu'il faut ensuite
corriger donc ça peut générer un peu de
complexité et vous savez
le système parfait n'existe pas donc
quand vous parlez de péréquation tout le
monde est à la recherche du système où
il n'y a que des bénéficiaires et pas de
contributeurs bon voilà donc sur l'IR on
va chercher on va sur la l'autonomie
fiscale on va rechercher le système où
on est le plus autonome possible avec le
moins de concurrence possible bon c'est
les choix politiques à poser la la
conscient de cette absence de de
consensus entre président de région
le minimum en tout cas ce qui nous
paraissait un minimal nécessaire c'est
cette codécision que j'ai évoquée dire
s'il n'y a pas d'autonomie fiscale au
moins qu'il y ait cette codécision dans
un cadre encore une fois qui reste à
définir donc je réponds cela à la fois
il y a des approches différentes soyons
simplement conscients des contraintes
d'un système ou d'un autre
et soyons conscients de ce que
l'autonomie fiscale génère en mécanisme
correcteur nécessaire correcteur des
effets sièges correcteur des écarts de
richesse etc etc c'est un vrai sujet
ensuite sur la contractualisation et sur
les mobilités qui ont été évoquées
dans les deux questions alors la
complexité elle est venue du fait que
les CPER ont été dévitalisés
nous ne sommes plus dans la
contractualisation et dans la
planification rocardienne
et d'ailleurs l'exemple on l'a eu
puisque les CPV ont été conclus sans
voler mobilité
et nous attendons aujourd'hui que les
préfets soient destinataires des mandats
de l'État pour négocier les volets
mobilité des CPAS et donc nous sommes
dans l'inconnu et les régions vont
devoir intégrer dans leur plan uranuels
d'investissement
des dépenses d'investissement sur
lesquels elles nous ont aujourd'hui pas
éclairé
donc avec un RER à Brest le sénateur qui
a des bêtes bon bref et puis je pense
qu'avant de parler recette il faut
parler modèle économique
moi pour avoir suivi au Conseil national
d'évaluation des normes par exemple les
décrets sur les redevances ferroviaires
c'est un monde totalement opaque
totalement au pack
j'ai souvenir de combat mener au cnen
sur ce sujet sur le les redevances
ferroviaires des décrets qui ont parfois
été appris après à vie
négatif de la affaire
bref beaucoup de questionsnements et
puis les modèles de financement finances
d'infrastructures alors je vais
emprunter une métaphore que je dois à
l'un de vos collègues qu'il sénateur
làlec qui a été un long praticien des
mobilités en région Bretagne et qui nous
disait c'est
métaphe c'est comme la kermesse d'école
vous avez une kermesse d'école le samedi
avec vos enfants donc il faut faire le
gâteau donc le vendredi vous faites le
gâteau que vous portez à la kermesse et
puis le samedi c'est le jour de la
kermesse d'école et vous rachetez une
part du gâteau que vous avez vous-même
apporté bon aujourd'hui mécanisme il est
bien celui-là SNCF réseau ne met parfois
que 8% du coût de l'infrastructure donc
nous investissons sur des
infrastructures qui nous appartiennent
pas majoritairement et quand je dis
majoritairement c'est quand vous mettez
la part contributive des régions mais
aussi parfois des intercommunalités
desservies par le ferroviaire vous
arrivez à des taux qui sont très élevés
et SNCF réseau que 8%. alors que nous ne
sommes pas propriétaires
d'infrastructure sauf les quelques cas
je pense son grand test ou en Occitanie
ou les régions ont pris la
responsabilité de quelques petites
lignes pour ne pas les voir complètement
fermées
et ensuite une fois que nous avons
financé l'investissement mais nous
faisons rouler nos notaires et nous
payons une redevance ferroviaire aux
propriétaires et donc on est un système
Shadok qui est très coûteux
à cela s'ajoute un problème conjoncturel
que la présence d'Elga évoquée avec la
première ministre qui en ce moment les
coûts qui nous sont facturés par SNCF
qui nous répercute une hausse liée au
coût d'énergie mais dont on ne sait pas
très bien si ça correspond au coût réel
effectivement assumée par SNCF
donc il y a des clarifications très
fortes à faire déjà sur le modèle de
financement
investissement plus fonctionnement
avant peut-être de voir ou d'envisager
d'autres mécanismes de recettes le
président farandou a dit sur coup pour
la SNCF de l'énergie a mis un peu plus
d'un milliard à milliard 6 de mémoire et
c'est 500 millions à la charge des
régions on demande en discuter
et on est en train d'en discuter donc il
faut clarifier absolument le modèle de
financement sur le ferroviaire qui est
d'une opacité beaucoup trop importante
pour qu'on agisse en confiance et après
sur le reste de la mobilité je redis ce
que j'ai dit tout à l'heure votre
mission d'information elle va arriver au
bon moment aussi parce qu'aujourd'hui on
est arrivé au bout d'un système
on sait très bien aujourd'hui que il
faut financer le transport vers les
métropoles par exemple de des passions
vers la métropole de salariés qui
n'habitent pas ces métropoles nous ne
sommes pas
attributaires du versement mobilité ou
d'une partie du versement mobilité et
donc nous devons assumer cette charge-là
avec nos propres ressources est-ce qu'il
faut imaginer un versement mobilité
additionnelle est-ce qu'il faut créer
des mécanismes de mobilité gérer à
l'échelle des aires de vie je dis pas
répliquer Île-de-France mobilité mais
est-ce qu'il faut le faire à des
échelles régional c'est des questions
qu'il faut poser mais ça méritant soin
un travail de fond qui va très au-delà
de sujets que nous évoquons aujourd'hui
mais compte tenu du poids du de la
compétence mobilité dans les budgets
régionaux il faudra bien qu'on y passe
et qu'on se coordonne il s'agit pas
d'opposer les régions enfin région de
France et la DCF nous avons intérêt à
travailler main dans la main parce que
pour nos concitoyens à qui nous rendons
le service au final il s'en fiche de
savoir qu'il franchit la limite d'une
autorité organisatrice de mobilité il
valait d'un point A à un point B et si
possible avec un coût acceptable
donc voilà et quand elle est fait grande
ou petite région
moi j'ai le bonheur de notre région qui
n'a pas fusionné je m'en réjouis souvent
parce que quand je vois ce qu'on a eu
assumer les collègues qui ont été fondus
dans des très grandes régions ça veut
dire que par exemple pour reprendre
l'exemple des mobilités la taille
désormais très inégales des régions
implique des organisations différentes
vous n'organisez pas les mobilités en
Bretagne région à 4 départements
peut-être 5 jours je n'ouvre pas ce
débat mais en tout cas quatre
départements et des régions comme Grand
Est
occitaniques qui ont 11 12 13
départements et qui ont redélégué au
département par exemple la compétence
transport scolaire et donc il faudra
imaginer les espaces de différenciation
en tout cas créer les possibilités de
contractualisation peut-être un peu
différente parce que ça ne s'organise
pas la même façon mais sur la capacité
par exemple à investir je ne pense pas
que ça a eu des faits et d'ailleurs
quand on fait le bilan en tout cas au
plan budgétaire de l'effet de ces
fusions les économies annoncées ne sont
pas là
et les économies d'échelle sur des
fusions de collectivité ou sur des
périmètres de collectivités ça ne marche
pas enfin on n'est pas en train on n'est
pas en train on n'est pas en charge de
produire des boulons à la chaîne enfin
ce n'est pas dans un modèle
tel que Smith l'économie civisme des
crevets où on fait des économies
d'échelle c'est voilà on produit du
service public des politiques publiques
ça ne marche pas comme ça donc je pense
que c'est totalement neutre néanmoins
dans la mise en oeuvre aujourd'hui des
politiques publiques évidemment ça
implique d'intégrer ce critère de
différenciation parce que les
problématiques peuvent être assez
différentes d'une région à une autre
contenu des tailles qui sont très
différentes et donc des potentiels ou
des besoins qui sont très différents
voilà monsieur le Président merci à nous
merci de
de vos réponses
je pense qu'il faudrait être attentif à
la façon dont le décret attendu
d'ailleurs depuis quelques mois
maintenant mais qui ne va pas tarder
j'en doute pas sur la répartition de la
TVA suite à la suppression de la CVAE va
se traduire puisque je vous rappelle
qu'elle ne part fixe et une part qui
doit être fonction
du développement
économique
local donc
selon selon le
travail qui va être fait là-dessus le
choix qui va être retenu peut être de
nature à influencer le même choix si je
puis dire dans la répartition de d'un
impôts voilà donc soyez attentifs je
vous le dis à ce décret la façon dont ça
va se traduire parce que il y a beaucoup
d'hésitations
nous-mêmes bon au-delà de de
positionnement qui ont pu être pour
certains négatifs sur le la suppression
même de la CME y revenons pas c'est du
passé au-delà de ça une fois de plus on
a
différé c'est beaucoup d'air parce que
l'Assemblée nationale ne l'a pas fait et
nous avons voté contre et il semblerait
quand même qu'on est légiféré pour la
suppression de CCE
certains
j'ai un député à plus tard qui a osé me
dire le truc de cette façon là j'étais
obligé de le reprendre publiquement
personne ne l'avait voté ni à
l'Assemblée ni au Sénat donc ce qui
était quand même nouveau
avant de réaliser une suppression
d'impôts cette nature mais c'est vrai
qu'on aurait gagné à avoir la clé de
répartition précisée dans le texte donc
on sait pas
donner du goût
enfin ça fait des mois et des mois en
réalité que Bercy travaille sur le sujet
sans trouver exactement la clé donc
l'acte qu'on trouvera là sur cette
espèce de répartition de de la pour
encourager les territoires les États
communalités à créer à créer de la
richesse c'est le même sujet que le
sujet régional certaines façons alors
certes
un peu moins parce que les régions c'est
dans leur
vie de base en dehors même de la
création de richesse c'est aussi la
création d'emploi sur grand territoire
il y a pas la question de la
territorialisation au sens des des
difficultés qui peuvent être engendrées
en termes de pollution de tel ou tel
industrie ou de risque qu'il a
concernant davantage l'intercommunalité
que la région dans son ensemble si je
puis dire bon mais tout de même le point
mérite d'être étudié de près puisque il
pourrait être une s'il était bien ceci
est bien ficelé et pour être aussi une
clé finalement de répartition d'un
impôts national
au niveau un peu de société
voilà merci merci beaucoup et nous
poursuivons avec les départements sans
doute dans le même esprit positif
[Applaudissements]
bien mes chers collègues si vous
permettez nous allons donc poursuivre
nos travaux
avec l'audition maintenant de
l'Assemblée des départements de France
comme je l'ai rappelé tout à l'heure
l'une des idées majeures qui se dégage
du rapport de la Cour et celle de
concentrer la fiscalité locale sur le
seul bloc communal une telle évolution
aurait notamment pour conséquence de
retirer au Département des droits de
mutation à titre onéreux qui constituent
leur dernière grande ressources de
fiscalité directe et bien entendu nous
nous souhaitons que ce sujet complexe
soit au cœur de nos échanges
certes dans la cordialité mais sans
doute avec comment dire des expressions
claires sur le sujet
cette audition constitue également
l'occasion de connaître les observations
des départements sur les autres
propositions épistes est-ce qu'il sait
par la Cour par exemple en matière de
gouvernance on a fini par ce point tout
à l'heure des finances locales ou de
simplification de la fiscalité
transférée nous accueillons donc Madame
Valérie Simonet président concéder
parental de la Creuse et secrétaire
adjointe de l'Assemblée des départements
de France
le président Christian Charpy il a
rapporteur général madame Mathilde
lignaud lelun for le plaisir de rester
avec nous mais c'est la dernière la
dernière voilà on se reverra après mais
sans doute sur des points ensuite plus
internes mais la dernière audition donc
avant de donner la parole à présent de
Simonet je vais céder la parole à
beaucoup rapporteur Charles Guinée en
excusant le rapporteur général qui est
également co rapporteur mais qui est
malheureusement souffrant
merci monsieur le président
madame la secrétaire
almouin madame la Présidente je voudrais
ajouter mes remerciements à ceux du
président
et également je voudrais compléter des
questions que vient d'évoquer le
président rénal en matière de
gouvernance vous savez que la Cour est
mis
un avis et après avoir
procéder à certains constats et la
gouvernance systémique nous intéresse
beaucoup
dans cette commission et le rapport
préconise à cet égard
soit une une autorité indépendante
ou alors
un CFL peut-être consolidé pour arriver
à un petit peu à arbitrer dans la mesure
où avec les parts d'impôts nationaux qui
qui vont croissants qui vont croissantes
et et
il semble qu'il faille quelque part
arbitrer à la fois entre l'État et
l'ensemble des collectivités comme entre
les différentes les différents types de
collectivités qui peuvent aussi avoir
des répartitions alors quel serait
plutôt votre choix sachant que
l'ensemble des collectivités que nous
avons entendues privilégie plutôt une
évolution du CFA disons il semble les
autorités indépendantes
plaisent moi et par ailleurs comme
nous sommes avec les départements et il
y a une proposition de la cour si j'ose
dire qui décoiffe un peu plus dans la
mesure où on propose
de revenir sur l'affectation des DMTO et
bon
quelque part sans doute des choses à
nous dire à cet égard mais
avant tout on voit que ça remettrait en
cause le principe de péréquation que
vous avez mis en place etc et
qu'on sent quand même malgré tout comme
une nécessité au niveau de d'impôts
nationaux quelle qu'il soit et bon on
peut sans doute un avis là-dessus et on
a également la piste d'un transfert
d'impôt sur le revenu qui serait réparti
sur nos critères de ressources et de
charge et nous nous interrogeons un
petit peu
dès lors qu'une ressource de fiscalité
est répartie en fonction d'autres
critères que celui de son assiette
est-ce qu'il s'agit toujours d'une
fiscalité transférée est-ce que ça ça va
rentrerait pas plutôt à une dotation
sachant que
si on a trop de territorialisation comme
on l'a entendu tout à l'heure on est
obligé de revenir à des pères équations
donc
je ne considère pas que les dotations
sont forcément des choses horribles
essentiel étant de savoir si elles sont
elles suivent l'évolution naturelle des
choses et de l'économie voilà je
m'arrêterai là c'était simplement pour
compléter un petit peu les les questions
les interrogations mais je crois que le
Président
vous a demandé de réagir globalement
donc allez-y aussi bien sûr dans votre
réaction
aux choses et puis par rapport à des
événements qui sont passés déjà dans le
passé c'est la manière de
fonctionner puisqu'il y a eu avec la
réforme de la TH par exemple il y a eu
effectivement des modifications déjà de
ressources
significatives pour les départements
donc avoir un petit regard sur le passé
pour pouvoir finalement après après coup
comment les choses finalement ont
modifié ce sont modifiés positivement ou
négativement quel est votre ressenti sur
les modifications passées
et puis après votre regard sur le sujet
actuel alors je voudrais juste refaire
une phrase c'est que le Parlement
peut-être à considérer qu'après des
années des années et des années de
réflexion d'associations d'élus
n'arrivant pas à se mettre d'accord
entre elles c'est le moins compliqué
il revenait peut-être par le monde de
poser un certain nombre d'actes et en
particulier
de demander effectivement à la cour
de nous faire des propositions un peu
extérieures si je peux dire je suis
utilisé le terme de tiers de confiance
tout à l'heure pour essayer de poser cet
un nombre de solutions qui sont sur la
table et qui pourraient être négocié
mais si vous voulez
l'idée que d'un côté tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que le système actuel
ne peut pas perdurer notamment en
particulier pour le financement des des
collectivités
du bloc communal par exemple ou là les
choses sont au bout du bout du bout du
bout
qu'il faille avancer et en même temps
c'est incapacité institutionnelles a
réellement avancé voilà donc on peut pas
satisfaire et donc à un moment donné il
revient de faire une espèce de constat
d'échec sur la capacité des acteurs à
trouver eux-mêmes une solution et donc à
faire des propositions pour essayer d'en
sortir c'est dans ce cadre là que
finalement nous avons demandé cette
étude et cette réflexion à la couronne
lui demandant en plus non seulement de
poser les choses j'allais dire de
manière théorique mais nous proposer un
modèle
préférentiel bon ce qui est peut-être
pas l'habitude de la cour je puis dire
mais qui est un engagement que nous lui
avons demandé
un petit peu de
d'avancer et forcément de susciter
quelques réactions c'est c'est si on
n'avait pas eu ce serait pas très bon
donc on vous attend sur ce thème et avec
vous explications pour éventuellement
nous montrer ce qui peut être retenu
dans le travail de la cour et ceux qui
selon vous ne pose réellement des
problèmes
madame la Présidente merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur rapporteur mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs membres de la
commission des finances je salue bien
évidemment les représentants monsieur le
Président de la Cour des comptes si vous
me le permettez peut-être me présenter
assez rapidement et peut-être cela
éclairera aussi sur ma vision des choses
qui doit être avant tout bien sûr celle
de mes collègues de l'Assemblée
départementale de France mais elle sera
teintée de par le fait que je suis
finalement conseillère générale depuis
2004 donc les grandes réformes
décentralisations particuliers sur les
allocations de solidarité et de fait de
la compensation financière que l'on
connaît aujourd'hui que l'on constate
vont impacter aussi sur le fait que je
suis élue vous le savez d'un département
des plus ruraux après la Lozère la
Creuse aujourd'hui on est à peine à
116000 habitants
un territoire où les gens vieillissent
très bien d'ailleurs mais où les
problématiques sont sensiblement
différentes d'autres départements mais
le vrai défi aujourd'hui qui qui est
devant notre nation française c'est
aussi celui d'apporter des réponses au
vieillissement de la population et tout
ce que cela induit donc il y a eu dans
une toute petite commune qui est
aujourd'hui à 88 habitants et j'en suis
resté donc adjointe et
première vice-président d'une communauté
de communes qui a fusionné trois petites
communautés de communes et aujourd'hui
13000 habitants dans un paysage de neuf
intercommunalités dans le département de
la Creuse donc
mon discours est forcément aussi
orienté au travers de ce qui se passe
d'une réalité autour des différentes
lois d'orientation au sujet de ces
réformes territoriales donc je vous
remercier mesdames et messieurs déjà de
du thon que vous consacrez à ces
auditions et donc à l'accueil que vous
faites à l'Assemblée des départements de
France j'en excuse le
le président du pont aussi qui sont tous
les deux retenus et président du pont
président de la commission des finances
je remercie évidemment donc la Cour des
comptes pour les travaux qui ont été
conduits avec le grand intérêt que nous
y avons lu et que nous partageons je
tente aussi souvent que je peux d'être
au CFN aussi pour les départements de
France donc ce sont des sujets dont que
nous avons largement évoqué
parliez du CFA l'intérêt que j'y vois
aussi avant de parler de la gouvernance
c'est de pouvoir échanger et d'écouter
surtout les différentes visions
perceptions orientation que chacune des
collectivités locales ou pas
collectivité intercommunalité en
particulier et bien peuvent exprimer
dans ce cadre là
je crois qu'on va pas se cacher de cela
le président Jean-Louis Dupont
a fait quelques observations
elles ont été plutôt claires et dans une
réaction
quasi immédiate à la lecture donc de ces
repas et en tout cas du scénario qui
potentiellement pourrait être retenu
je crois que départements de France
partage comme vous l'avez rappelé
messieurs les éléments de constat autour
du nécessité aujourd'hui qui est celle
en effet de repenser les recettes le
gagner de recettes des collectivités
voyant bien que certains plus que
d'autres mais si on regarde sur une
période plus ou moins courte ou longue
en tout cas il est difficile de dire
qu'aucune collectivité n'a besoin d'être
de nouveau dans un discours autour de
ces questions là avec avec le
gouvernement
mais voilà je reviendrai sur
l'étonnement peut-être qu'à partager
monsieur Dupont mais mais beaucoup plus
largement nos collègues autour donc de
ce scénario qui semblerait retenu qui
est celui de la suppression après
d'autres du produit des DMTO
ce qui conduirait en effet les conseils
départementaux à être exclusivement
dans une dans les ressources qui
seraient les leurs d'être donc sur une
redistribution de fiscalité nationale
partagée et des dotations
je ne l'ai pas aller jusqu'à rappeler à
le principe constitutionnel d'autonomie
des collectivités
évidemment que que ce respect des
ressources propres nous permet ou pas en
effet grâce à ou pas une autonomie
financière d'être libre en
l'administration de dessiner les
politiques qui sont les nôtres pour
autant pour autant
dire que nous avons quelques exemples
qui nous font réagir je pense peut-être
plus fortement que d'autres strates de
collectivités et vous l'avez évoqué non
pas allez c'est derrière nous la
suppression de la taxe d'habitation mais
pour être vraiment dans quelque chose de
très factuel qui s'est déroulée donc
depuis au cours de l'année 2022 en fait
c'est 21 la suppression du foncier bâti
nous avons noté et on ne peut que le
constater que l'année 2021 fut une année
blanche alors que cependant les bases
ont été revalorisées et que logiquement
mathématiquement les recettes sans même
bouger les taux aurait été supérieur en
2021 à ce qu'elles ont été en 2020 en
2021 année particulière aussi ou tout
son fut constater l'effort des
départements et en tout cas leur
participation à l'effort national
demandée pour faire part à la crise
sanitaire aux côtés des régions des
intercommunalités des communes et de
l'état bien évidemment
je reviens à la suppression du foncier
bâti donc 2021 année blanche que
s'est-il passé en 2022 on a donc
construit nos budgets sur une annonce
qui était celle de la progression
attendue de la part perçue par l'État en
terme d'augmentation donc de recettes
TVA qui était si je ne me trompe autour
de 5,5%. donc les budgets se
construisent sur cela fin 2021 2022
quand ils sont votés
en cours d'année on revient vers un taux
qui n'était plus que de 2,9 donc
décision modificative dans les
collectivités pour là aussi repréciser
les recettes et voir si au niveau des
dépenses on continue à tenir la route
fin d'année 2022 avec bonheur on est à
plus de 9 9 8%
redécision modificatives ou bien
évidemment
on la voit une situation qui compense
peu ou selon la les collectivités selon
les départements
les augmentations de dépenses qui nous
ont été demandés j'imagine je pense au
point d'indice je pense à l'augmentation
du RSA et d'autres quand dans le même
temps nous avions nous avions au cours
de l'année 2022 était dans la démarche
souhaitée souhaitable du gouvernement de
la reversation des métiers d'aide à
domicile l'avenant 43 puis le Ségur etc
donc je crois que globalement et nous
savons très bien que tout cela n'a pas
été compensé à 100% par l'État
nous étions présents nous avons
accompagné cette volonté du gouvernement
et donc fait en sorte que les recettes
nouvelles avec cette part de TVA et bien
puisse compenser en partie ses dépenses
et puis aujourd'hui nous apprenons que
finalement
cette
revalorisation de la de la perception
par l'état de la TVA va être moindre à
8,56 de mémoire ce qui fait qu'on nous
annonce aujourd'hui que sur 2023 alors
que les budgets sont votés pour certains
ou sont en face de l'être et bien il va
falloir en rendre une partie
seulement pour vous dire qu'en 12 13
mois
la difficulté à prévoir
clairement concrètement et ce n'est que
sur une année
la part de recettes réelles au regard de
cette suppression donc du foncier bâti
qu'on pensait par une part de thé vert
vous dire cela pourquoi parce que ça y
est on le constate déjà les comptes
administratifs 2022 ne sont pas
officiellement présentés mais on le sait
on se début d'année la capacité
d'autofinancement des collectivités
départementales chute et d'ailleurs cela
nous savons de combien les collectivités
départementales accompagnent à la fois
le développement économique des
territoires par la commande publique que
ce soit pour nos propres besoins
de la Creuse mais aussi bien sûr
par l'accompagnement que l'on apporte
aux collectivités communes PCI syndicat
et là est bien notre inquiétude réel
avoir que deux mains face à des grands
défis qui sont ceux par exemple de la
compagnement à la transition écologique
et environnemental
la rénovation du bâti nous sommes par
exemple en Creuse porteur depuis 2016
d'un programme
partagé avec les intercommunalités mais
sous pilotage du conseil départemental
pour la NA et c'est bien cette équipe
mutualisée qui permet d'avoir un
résultat clair une vision claire sur ce
que l'on peut faire en matière
d'accompagnement d'ingénierie mais aussi
d'être complémentaire au programme
habitat
pour évidemment parler du grand défi qui
est celui du grand cycle de l'eau depuis
les
espaces naturels sensibles la protection
de la ressource le partage de la
ressource les questions de la protection
aussi de la ressource avec au-delà de la
distribution et bien les questions
d'assainissement aujourd'hui les
conseils départementaux sont là avec les
moyens qui sont les leurs appuyez aussi
sur les DMT ou bien sûr et bien en
capacité d'apporter de l'ingénierie
technique concrète adaptée à nos
territoires et évidemment d'accompagner
de façon financière les collectivités
donc le sujet des DMTO qui nous
intéressent et qui évidemment pour les
départements
nous sommes pas favorables cette cette
privation de ressources qui a été
dynamique ces trois dernières années
pour nous permet de conserver aussi ce
lien entre le territoire et ce que nous
pouvons faire pour le territoire en
matière d'aménagement et développement
local et puis que s'est-il passé avec
les dmteo que nous avons perçu c'est la
mise en place d'un fonds de péréquation
je citerai encore un exemple dans mon
département la baisse de la DGF
2014-2017 nous avons perdu peu au Prous
6 millions d'euros
sont cette volonté entre les
départements entre les conseils
départementaux de créer un fonds de
péréquation avec nos critères à nous et
bien je puis vous dire que nous serions
très en retard aujourd'hui sur nos
investissements nous avions
exprimé entre nous d'ailleurs au moment
de cette discussions tout le monde en
n'était pas forcément d'accord que
je l'ai dit clairement ma collègue de la
Lozère aussi je me souviens et d'autres
qu'une dotation de péréquation entre
départements devraient et c'est ce que
nous avons fait être cibler sur les
investissements les investissements
d'avenir nous nous l'avons consacré par
exemple au déploiement du très haut
débit de la fibre dans beaucoup de
départements en France ce ne sont pas
des opérateurs privés l'opérateur
historique qui construit le réseau de
fibres ce sont des collectivités et en
premier lieu avec l'aide de l'État et
des régions mais porté par les
départements dans un schéma
de déploiement départemental et je puis
vous dire qu'aujourd'hui heureusement
que les départements sont là et peuvent
financer le déploiement de ce réseau
parce que les intercommunalités pour
beaucoup sont en incapacité financière
de le faire donc là aussi ce sont ce
sont des liens de confiance et presque
de sécurité dans un modèle de
développement local que nous permettent
aussi aujourd'hui c'est des MTO ce fonds
de péréquation et puis pour pour
rappeler mais bien évidemment que que
vous connaissez tous cela encore mieux
que moi le fond de peréquation là aussi
des MTO à l'échelle nationale
les engagements que nous prenons et dont
nous des bâtons avec le CFL chaque année
au-delà du 1 milliard 6 nous décidons
nous proposons au CFL de mettre en
réserve peu ou proue les sommes
récoltées au-delà de cette somme là ce
montant là et
c'est entre nous finalement que nous
choisissons d'utiliser ou pas chaque
année et nous avons pu démontrer que
lorsque nous avons demandé une
redistribution de l'enveloppe c'était
aussi parce que nous faisions face à des
difficultés donc la question elle est
elle est essentielle pour nous elle est
probablement celle de la confiance de
l'État envers nos capacités à bien faire
il faut regarder ce que nous sommes en
en partie capable de faire non pas
seulement pour nous pour les politiques
et les politiques sociales de solidarité
que nous mettons en place que nous
accompagnons mais aussi ce que nous
faisons pour les autres strates de
collectivité voilà pourquoi il est
difficile pour nous d'entendre que après
le foncier bâti après la TH et autres
demain
nous n'aurions plus de libre arbitre en
quelque sorte autour de ces solidarités
territoriales et de ce que nous
pourrions faire je crois que c'est un
contrat local qui qui est en passe
d'être rompu et
sont sont du tout vouloir braver
quelques évolutions que ce soit et même
si nous en arrivions là
à poursuivre notre investissement notre
engagement à faire du développement
local
il est évident que que cette réforme
risque fortement de mettre en péril
demain dans un contexte dans un contexte
voilà qui est inquiétant aussi pour les
collectivités mais pour les départements
tout particulièrement
cet accompagnement et à savoir que on
est fait si les régions s'occupent des
missions que sont celles des régions les
départements que sont celles des
départements les intercommunalités de ce
qu'elles peuvent faire avec et pour les
communes et les communes
cela va je pense rendre plus difficile
une organisation
finalement nationale une je parlais tout
à l'heure de contrat local mais
probablement aussi de contrat moral au
regard de ce que nous voulons faire de
notre pays et autant la crise sanitaire
a pu démontrer que collectivement nous
arrivions à faire face je pense
sincèrement que dans les temps qui
arrivent
et ton qui risque de perdurer aussi si
ce contrat entre les collectivités ne
peut être maintenue
encourager allez-je dire même par l'État
et bien je me dis que que ce
gouvernement et ceux qui lui succéderont
probablement
rencontreront de vrais et réelles
difficultés face à aujourd'hui nous le
savons tous
question de la démocratie la question de
la démocratie locale de la participation
de la compréhension de par nos citoyens
aujourd'hui sur l'organisation de notre
République risque d'être réellement mis
à mal
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
faire peut-être une première réaction
à vos propos d'abord parce que vous êtes
dans une maison
qui certes comprend les hommes et des
femmes qui ont pu être ou qui sont qui
peuvent être conseiller régionaux mais
pour beaucoup un passé de mer est
conseillé départementaux vous le savez
donc c'est une maison qui
a l'habitude en tout cas de bien
connaître les départements
leur position leur histoire
longue et peut-être avez-vous dans votre
exposé montrer par la tonalité
l'inquiétude un peu sous-jacente
toujours sur
les départements de demain que
pouvons-nous faire serons-nous toujours
là vous l'avez pas dit dans ces termes
mais on sent dans votre propos quelque
chose cette histoire de la mise en cause
si je puis dire qui a été le
millefeuille est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
supprimer
le conseiller territorial
toute une histoire qui finalement a mis
en cause l'existence même des
départements à des moments donnés
avant que me semble-t-il il soit d'une
certaine façon réhabiliter
encore encore récemment si je puis dire
seront le même qu'on recrée des
sous-préfectures
il est un territorial il y a des choses
qui se passent qui sont de nature me
semble-t-il
et que dans votre exposé vous avez
rappelé les fonctions d'un département
les fonctions nouvelles d'un département
aussi il y en a et notamment
d'organisation entre interco département
qui est très clair très visible
et très utile
la réforme va alors
on n'est pas au stade d'une réforme au
stade de proposition il faut les prendre
toujours au sérieux les propositions
parce que effectivement c'est une
convienne pas il faut le dire en parler
et c'est bien l'objet d'aujourd'hui en
tout cas il me semble et en tout cas le
Sénat ne le vit pas comme vous si je
puis dire
ne vit pas ses propositions là comme des
propositions de remise en cause de
l'échelon des partenaires et de ses
compétences de ses capacités à faire en
tout cas on s'inscrit pas du tout cette
vision là est de ce que nous lisons nous
du rapport de la Cour nous ne lisons pas
ça
nous disons plutôt une question qui est
une question de
finalement comment organiser les choses
à l'avenir pour que les la visibilité
des finances des départements comme des
autres niveaux
de collectivités soit
au bon au bon niveau c'est-à-dire que
vous ayez une visibilité permettant
d'engager les investissements de
mener vos travaux etc
les DMTO j'étais moi-même conseillé
général pas des départementales
les DMTO on a connu des phases
extrêmement difficiles
de baisse extrêmement difficile
on s'habitue au confort de recettes
importantes et quand survient la crise
nous laisse comme on disait la fontaine
près des pourvu
donc
a connu ça le fait que aujourd'hui des
DNT au très élevé ne signifie pas que
demain le restaurant c'est une évidence
d'où d'ailleurs les propositions qui ont
été faites
par la déesse de pouvoir etter d'une
certaine façon et garder en réserve etc
donc il y avait il y a bien ce sentiment
qu'on est bien sur une recette
incertaine
dans la proposition de la cour il y a
l'idée de rendre
que le côté incertain de la recette soit
plutôt pris en charge par l'État que par
les collectivités c'est un peu vrai de
toutes les propositions qu'ils ont
faites pour tous les niveaux de
collectivité c'est à dire de
faire en sorte que les côtés incertains
sont plutôt assumés par l'État que par
des collectivités elle-même
je pense que ça cette réflexion là
est plutôt de bonne aloi
après qu'il faut là
c'est plutôt comme ça qu'il faut voir la
réponse deuxième niveau je suis un peu
étonné je le dis
je suis très heureux que ça soit vous
qui soyez venu je vous le dis
d'abord vous en souvenez plus mais vous
avez audité pendant la
crise en visio je me souviens très bien
de vous et de nos échanges et d'autre
part parce que vous représentez un
département
qu'on qualifiera de port
ons que ça
c'est bien vous avez toujours la même
vision les gens de la Creuse nous avons
deux sénateurs ici je vais bien nous
connaissons
et moi je suis célibataire d'un
département riche
les moyens de faire sont considérables
et donc je me dis département peu riche
pourrait être pour être dans l'absolu
à une intéressée par un système plus
avec une vision nationale une
répartition nationale en fonction des
besoins etc plus clarifier on est
incertaine et moins lié finalement un
accord entre départements qui tient
aujourd'hui qui est là aujourd'hui mais
c'est un accord c'est c'est pas la loi
et donc ça pourrait vous rendre plus
plus solide alors voilà donc il y a une
vision département association
départements que je comprends totalement
que vous portez et il y a une vision
semble-t-il
d'un certain nombre de territoires qui
auraient plus à gagner peut-être avoir
un système plus national qu'un système
ce qu'est le cas exactement
des des petites communes etc moi je suis
toujours très étonné de voir des maires
de communes rurales passionnés par
l'autonomie fiscale je trouve ça
fabuleux ils ont pas de base ils ont
aucune envie d'augmenter les impôts quoi
qu'il arrive même s'ils ont des impôts
ils ne le feront pas et donc mais par
contre c'est des héros de la cause de
l'autonomie fiscale
sauf qu'il n'y a aucun intérêt
je comprends parfaitement que la ville
de Toulouse demande de l'autonomie
fiscale voyez ce que je veux dire
mais je suis toujours étonné qu'un
village de montagne la réclama sur le
même avec le même bruit si ce n'est plus
forte fiscale pour surtout dire dans la
lettre aux 80 habitants que vous
sollicitiez toujours tout leur dire dans
la lettre de campagne de leur dire que
bien entendu et hors de question
d'augmenter les impôts on démarre par ça
gérant dans la même lettre on dit qu'on
l'a pas fait dans les six dernières
années et on s'engage à ne pas le faire
dans les six prochains donc conserver
une autonomie fiscale dans ces
conditions pas sûr que finalement une
amélioration des choses
je me bats en permanence j'essaie de le
faire toujours avec beaucoup d'humour
ça me sauve ça m'évite me faire couper
la tête si vous voulez bon c'est quand
même ça sujet et donc je pense que c'est
comme cela je crois qu'il ne faut pas
voir en tout cas une mesure particulière
au département ce qui est proposé là
c'est plutôt des solutions pour que les
sujets à risque soit mutualisés d'une
certaine façon les DMTO sont un sujet à
risque
et que finalement peut-être que la
position des départements négative
aujourd'hui vient plutôt de
l'accumulation d'un certain nombre de
retraits
qui fait qu'aujourd'hui l'impression que
la dmte est une autonomie fiscale mais
c'est pas une autonomie fiscale de météo
vous êtes tous généralement tous les
départements sont à peu près au plafond
de la possibilité donc il y a aucune
possibilité de le bouger sauf à la
baisse mais je suis pas sûr que ça
intéresse qui que ce soit
tout le monde est au plafond donc à
partir de là où est l'autonomie fiscale
sur la DMTO je cherche voilà donc c'est
pour ça que je crois qu'il faut
tranquillement avec une sérénité ce qui
manquait davantage c'est ce que vous
avez dit sur la TVA mais je n'ai pas
compris quand même que les augmentations
de TVA fut-elles
elles ont été un peu rabotées etc n'est
pas été super quand même à
l'augmentation des en particulier dans
les départements aussi de base de
fonciers et une évolution de fonciative
extrêmement limitée donc je pense qu'il
y a pas quand même j'ai pas entendu
grosse inquiétude bon il y a eu un petit
coup de rabot à un moment donné parce
qu'il y avait un espèce d'effet domaines
qui a été considéré comme une phénomène
peut-être il y a une déballe si j'y
reviens pas au-delà de ça il y a plutôt
eu un bien pour les départements à
passer sur une part de TVA que je suis
resté sur les bases de fonctionnatisme
sauf peut-être dans des départements qui
connaissent des qui sont appuyés sur des
métropoles extrêmement performantes
peut-être que là ça a été légèrement
moins beau mais après tout faut-il
s'amenouvoir
pose la question
alors ça c'était ma réaction
Stéphane Sautarel
merci monsieur le Président merci madame
la Présidente pour votre présentation je
vais reprendre en fait un questionnement
à voix haute plus que réellement des
interrogations sans préjugés des
hypothèses effectivement qui qui nous
sont proposés par la course ou la
manière dont très son travail je veux
rejoindre en partie je crois ce qu'a dit
le président rénal tout d'abord je
voulais noter
et pour vous en féliciter en termes de
d'autonomie de décision
le fait que vous ayez au sein des
départements étaient en capacité de
mettre en place une péréquation
horizontale en fait au niveau des DMTO
comme ça a été rappelé pour peut-être
éviter de subir une péréquation
verticale qui vous aurait échappé et
donc de trouver une gouvernance propre
interne au Conseil départementaux qui a
sa vertu je le dis d'autant plus que
dans une vie antérieure j'avais un peu
travaillé à la mise en place de celle-ci
et
médias effectivement eu le mérite de
fonctionner dans dans la période
je fais immédiatement le lien avec ma
deuxième remarque avoir un peu plus
haute qui est qui me semble-t-il pour le
niveau départemental cette question du
financement de la collectivité qui est
encore plus lié à la question de la
compétence et notamment du bloc social
parce que cette compétence est en grande
partie subie au sens de la capacité à
décider par la collectivité et donc en
conséquence effectivement il y a des
transferts financiers qui qui s'opèrent
et qui sont pas négligeables qui peuvent
même encore simplifier parce que non
seulement cette compétence elle est
subie en grande partie mais aujourd'hui
elle est encore partielle et on pourrait
s'imaginer que si demain il y a une
grande loi sur sur l'autonomie qui
arrive enfin la question et je parle moi
aussi d'un département rural de Cantal
et et
serait encore plus prégnante du coup par
rapport à ce contrat de confiance que
que vous appeliez ou que vous rappeliez
je pense que plus que pour d'autres
niveaux de collectivité encore la
question de l'exercice des compétences
et donc des charges qui sont liées à
cette compétence est encore plus
prégnant en lien avec les moyens les
ressources donc doit disposer le niveau
départemental donc des niveaux
effectivement
soit liés au territoire soit nationaux
avec peut-être effectivement une prise
en compte encore plus forte de ces
niveaux de richesse ce d'autant plus qui
me semble que pour ce qui concerne les
DMTO comment dire ça poliment il y a un
peu moins de liens entre la ressource et
l'effort de la collectivité on parlait
par exemple de la CVAE pour les
communautés de communes on pourrait
considérer qu'en fonction des efforts de
la collectivité de la communauté de
communes il y a une incidence sur le
produit de CVAE sur les DMTO on connaît
tous des départements qui spontanément
ou naturellement on des DMTO sans que ce
soit directement lié à la politique
publique qui conduisent donc c'est 12
points de vue là un impôt qui me semble
un peu plus national même s'il est
territorialisé et donc la question se
pose voilà dans un cadre un peu plus
largeur j'avais pas vraiment de
questions mais c'était plus un partage
de réflexion autour de de ces questions
là et savoir si vous partagiez cette
idée que en tout état de cause au-delà
du financement il y a un lien qui me
semble encore plus fort avec le
périmètre le champ de compétences et
peut-être l'autonomie de décision sur
les charges qui sont les vôtres pour une
grande part
merci Stéphane peut-être monsieur le
Président Charpy il y avait une autre
demande d'un collègues pardon
de la présidente
peut-être avoir une position après de
réponse par rapport à aux éléments que
nous avons pu apporter avec Stéphane
sotarel et aux propos de réponses du
président Charpy merci beaucoup oui
j'étais très très attentif aux propos
madame il faut reconnaître que les
auditions qui a fait la cour avant de
rendre publique son rapport la plus
musclée a été celle avec votre collègue
du Calvados
bonteurs de voleur mais tout ceci était
tout à fait sympathique mais on l'a bien
vu la sensibilité très forte du sujet
alors nous c'est pas une position
idéologique des MTO on n'a pas de
position énergique du Sud on a regardé
au fond s'il y avait quelques critères
qui justifiaient que les DMTO restent au
niveau départemental et
à part le fait qu'ils y sont depuis 1983
on n'a pas trouvé de choses totalement
évidentes c'est une ressource qui est
assez inégalitaire entre départements je
crois que le rapport est de 1 à 7 après
péréquation
sur la ressource par habitant ce qui est
tout à fait considérable je suis
moi-même d'un département proche de
nouveau c'est la Lozère donc je suis
contribuable aux airs je vois qu'elle
est l'importance des DMTO voilà c'est
une ressource qui est quand même très
inégale département à l'autre
deuxièmement c'est comme l'a dit le
monsieur sauterelle c'est pas une
ressource qui est directement en lien
avec la compétence de la collectivité
départements qui ont retrouvé toutes
leurs légitimité en partie grâce aux
grandes régions bon
une compétence plutôt sociale et le lien
avec les dmteo est assez faible quant à
l'action du département sur les dmteo en
tant que tel là aussi c'est pas de
l'action Christ c'est une recette de
constatation alors voilà c'est pour
toutes ces raisons-là qu'on s'est dit
c'est plus simple de le mettre au niveau
national plutôt et de les répartir en
fonction des besoins objectifs plutôt
que de garder le niveau départemental je
suis en même temps très sensible au fait
que c'est le dernier levier apparemment
mais non pas d'autonomie fiscale mais
mais d'un impôt de territorialisé voilà
et deuxièmement je reconnais que les
départements font un effort important à
la fois la mise en réserve la
péréquation voilà je dis simplement ça
nous a paru d'un point de vue technique
peut-être un peu technocratique probant
la plus simple des solutions dans un
univers où au fond il y a peu d'Apollo
[Musique]
concentrons sur le bloc communal
l'essentiel les impôts locaux qui en
sont qui sont de vrais Apollo et faisant
supporter par l'État les risques qui
sont sur aux impôts qui sont aujourd'hui
répartis soit la dmco qui est un Apollo
calme et qui n'est pas vraiment un
Apollo 4 sur le fond soit la TICPE ou
les certificats d'immatriculation qui
sont liées à l'automobile qui eux vont
évoluer donc faisons prendre à l'état le
risque bon une fois qu'on a dit ça il
faut effectivement que ça soit pas
marché de dupe et je reconnais que
parfois on peut avoir le risque d'avoir
un marché dupe dans des relations
financières entre l'État et que les =
c'est pour ça que nous la contrepartie
de ces évolutions qu'on met sur la table
on n'est pas là pour décider une informe
et qu'on met sur la table c'est dire il
faut qu'il rencontre partie des
mécanismes qui garantissent la
prévisibilité la juste compensation
l'équité entre les contribuables et les
bénéficiaires voilà c'est c'est pour ça
qu'on dit il faut que en parallèle une
instance le CFL rénové ou quelque chose
d'autre qui qui garantit ça voilà c'est
pas une position idéologique c'est pas
contre les départements et c'est surtout
pas pour pour fragiliser département
aujourd'hui c'est parce qu'on considère
que c'est plutôt assez logique voilà
tout ce que je on pourrait dire
merci monsieur le Président non
j'aimerais rajouter quelques éléments
alors je ne rajouterai pas au concert
des départements puisque moi-même étant
de la Haute-Marne avec la Lozère et la
Creuse je crois qu'on fait un bon trio
et je voudrais confirmé aussi que
effectivement
la problématique c'est c'est quand même
la volatilité quand même de
cdmto il fallait quand même essayer
d'imaginer quelque chose d'autre mais
quelque part on est obligé de dire que
c'est très difficile de trouver quelque
chose qui ne soit pas contracyclique
parce que
les départements
ayant enfin s'occupant j'allais dire de
la misère du monde c'est pas très facile
de trouver un impôt qui qui puisse
fonctionner en contrepartie et si vous
aviez une idée ça nous intéresserait on
pourrait dire ça comme ça mais bon je
conçois que vous n'ayez pas pu trouver
quelque chose de mieux mais je trouve
que l'IR finalement pourquoi pas c'est
quand même quelque chose qui doit
rarement baisser même si bon et le
deuxième point auquel vous n'avez pas
tout à fait répondu ou du moins pas
suffisamment pour moi mais vous avez
expliqué pourquoi on avait pas répondu
c'est au niveau de la gouvernance c'est
l'histoire des départements c'est une
une grande défiance vis-à-vis de l'État
quand même donc vous n'y croyez pas trop
à un organisme enfin disons une
gouvernance ou du moins vous vous en
méfiez
mais est-ce que pourriez nous en dire
plus parce qu'a priori on a quand même
des pays qui nous entourent même s'ils
sont de structures différentes et qui
arrive quand même à la fois à négocier
avec l'État mais aussi
je crois que et ce n'est pas moi qui
l'ai dit nous parlons de tous on ces
instants d'une question de confiance ou
défiance entre les collectivités donc là
en l'occurrence départementale et l'État
je repense à quelques exemples vous avez
en effet précisé de combien l'importance
dans nos politiques
en territoire en proximité sont celles
qui nous occupent le plus qui mobilisent
le plus nos budgets mais pas que
entière maximum ce sont les dépenses de
solidarité je ne vais que cibler les
allocations individuelles de solidarité
moi j'ai un petit peu de chance la
principale dépense et la pas c'est celle
qui est relativement le mieux compensé à
49% par l'État mais seulement à 49%
quand le RSA elle est beaucoup moins et
la PCH avec beaucoup d'inquiétude
puisque là aussi les nouvelles lois
justifiées nous incite à prévoir que les
montants des dépenses vont aller
grandement au-delà de ce que nous
connaissions jusqu'à présent
donc être confiant avec l'état des
centralisations allez disons peut-être
50%
d'un montant important de dépenses qui
n'est donc pas compensé contrairement à
ce qui avait été annoncé en effet donc
de par la loi la baisse de la DGF j'y
reviens
2014-2017 quelque chose de très simple
cela a été un volume demandé donc
d'efforts aux collectivités
mais nous avons au même pourcentage
réduit vu réduire notre DGF en Creuse
que dans les Yvelines ou ailleurs donc
là aussi on entend bien le péréquation
mais parfois l'État dans ses obligations
ou les difficultés qu'il rencontre aussi
a tendance à aller peut-être un peu trop
vite et oublier que nous ne sommes pas
tous au même niveau et n'avons pas tous
les mêmes besoins en tout cas sur cette
sur cette mesure pas de critères
de richesse ou de pauvreté ont été
intégrées
sujet très récent aussi la DGF une
augmentation de la DGF au regard de
l'inflation
l'énergie alimentation etc nous sommes
aussi énormément impactés mes collègues
le savent parfaitement les collèges etc
etc nous n'avons pas obtenu donc
d'indexation de notre DGF sur
l'inflation confiance ou pas envers
l'État l'état reconnaît-il les
difficultés les efforts que nous devons
faire aussi et puis ce que je n'ai pas
précisé tout à l'heure sur un certain
nombre d'autres dotations compensatoires
la DCP la dcrpp et les allocations
compensatrices en 2023 on sait que elle
chute énormément donc sur des éléments
tels que ceux-ci nous voyons déjà
aujourd'hui que l'État ne va pas en
termes de compensation être présent au
côté des départements alors c'est c'est
ça notre principale inquiétude c'est que
au moins vous avez raison la DMTO c'est
volatile etc moi je dois vous dire que
je n'ose même pas vous noter les vous
partagez le montant tellement ça vous
paraîtrait ridicule mais on creuse on a
doublé notre produit de dmteo en
l'espace de 3 ans et de ne pas
résolument dire au département en tout
cas départements ruraux qui ont vu cette
envolée importante que cela a aussi très
aux efforts et à ce que nous faisons
dans les collectivités départementales
je vous parlais tout à l'heure de la
fibre mais l'image de nos départements
qu'on est en train de changer les
politiques d'accueil que le monde est en
train de déployer quand on accompagne
les bourses qui sont un petites villes
de demain on met des moyens financiers
parce qu'on y croit on est persuadé que
demain les territoires héros seront
aussi probablement une réponse aux
difficultés que l'on connaît dans les
milieux beaucoup plus urbanisés mais
pour cela il nous faut faire de
l'aménagement de territoire et ça vous
paraît peut-être symbolique mais en tout
cas c'est c'est un starter aussi
un booster de se dire que on peut
mesurer non plus seulement à à des
chiffres qui sont ceux de la démographie
voire un solde migratoire les efforts
que nous pouvons faire avec ces
financements là parce qu'après tout si
j'ai des dotations de l'État qui
m'arrive que je sois que je fasse
quelque chose ou pas
quel intérêt aurais-je demain à ne pas
avoir une incitation en tout cas
mieux faire à toujours mieux faire et à
cibler en effet l'aménagement et le
développement local ça c'était
complément des éléments que je voulais
partager mais pour répondre à votre
question nous pour moi le CFL c'est bien
c'est l'organisation
partenariale dans laquelle nous pouvons
débattre
voilà échanger sur des positions qui
sont souvent différentes après je ne
saurais émettre d'avis parce que je ne
me suis pas posé cette question à savoir
quel est le poids
représentatif à l'intérieur du CFL
actuellement de chaque strat des
collectivités et là peut-être est aussi
dans une nouvelle gouvernance l'élément
sur lequel il nous faudrait travailler
les régions représentent je ne sais pas
si en fonction des budgets des
politiques etc les départements les
interco etc donc c'est peut-être cela
mais pour moi cet instant
intelligemment présidé allez je dire
par Monsieur Lenel en tout cas et un
endroit où l'on peut en effet partager
nos inquiétudes mais peut-être aussi
aller plus loin aujourd'hui et élaborer
des stratégies des pistes de réflexion
qui pourraient être proposées ensuite
différentes instances
bien merci il y aurait beaucoup de
choses
à échanger
il y aurait beaucoup de choses à
échanger en particulier je ne crois pas
que
sans DMTO votre esprit change voyez je
vous crois au dessus de ça je crois non
ce que je crois c'est que
il y a pas besoin de récompense cette
nature
pour comment dire s'engager c'est la
fonction même si on s'engage pas
démissionne
il faut que j'ai un politique sur des
fonctions d'engagement par nature donc
j'ai tendance à considérer que bien
d'autres valeurs comptent davantage que
de savoir si à la fin de l'année je suis
que vous ne le regardez pas puisque
c'est effectivement quelque chose mais
c'est surprenant les DMTO c'est à dire
quelquefois uniquement parce que le
permis est donné à tel moment où la fin
des travaux a tel moment c'est sur cette
année là où c'est sur l'année suivante
voir même encore plus loin si par
extraordinaire ce qui n'arrive jamais
bien sûr les gens ne déclarent pas par
exemple la fin des travaux vous avez des
choses comme ça vous avez des tas de
truc c'est bizarre qui se passe sur les
DMTO donc bon regardez ça avec un peu de
prudence je suis sûr que vous regardez
ça comme ça et que vous ferez du
développement parce que c'est la
fonction même des élus d'être
développeurs d'améliorer les conditions
pour ces concitoyens quel que soit en
quelque soit le quel que soit le système
ideo c'est aussi du One Shot
curieusement les endroits où il y a
beaucoup de tmto c'est des endroits où
finalement la population bouge beaucoup
c'est le mouvement de la population qui
fait qu'il y a des ventes et des
reventes et des survendes
donc c'est plutôt cette gesticulation si
je puis dire qui est assez proche qui
fait que finalement le système
métropolitain en profite à plein parce
que justement les emplois des systèmes
métropolitains font que les gens
viennent repartent pas dans une autre
métropole repartent à l'étranger et que
ça et quand même bâtiment se revend un
nombre incalculable de foi et ce n'est
pas par l'ajout de nouvelles
maisons bien sûr que oui mais c'est très
ponctuel de mon point de vue par rapport
à ce qui relève plus de du mouvement et
si on faisait par territoire une espèce
de représentation de ces mouvements vous
serez extraordinairement surprises enfin
pas vraiment parce que vous en doutez
mais on verrait des endroits où sont des
pelotes de mouvement si vous voulez et
des endroits où c'est de la joue
ponctuelle etc qui relève pas du tout de
la DMTO qui après relève plutôt de
l'impôt foncier d'une certaine façon là
où il y a une permanence dans l'impôt
foncier mais pas une permanence dans
l'admto bon on pourrait en discuter
pendant des heures nous ne le ferons pas
ce soir et on va vous remercier de votre
témoignage à double titre au titre de
votre association bien sûr la solution
de départements de France et au titre de
président de justement
qui a des spécifités des spécificités
particulières et qui sans doute
comment dire à plus de complexité me
semble-t-il à prendre parti dans cette
discussion
je ne doute pas que si j'avais le
président du Département
voyons des Hauts-de-Seine vous voyez
autour de la table
je suis sûr que sur le dmteo voyez
il toucherait le plafond déjà
donc mais ce que je veux dire les
différences entre départements
sont-elles
[Musique]
pas de schizophrénie c'est une évidence
la fin d'interrogation à savoir que
devant tout changement mais ça c'est la
nature humaine aussi nous savons ce que
nous perdons et malgré le contexte mais
jamais assuré de ce que nous risquons de
gagner et la réforme des indicateurs de
la DGF qui était en cours qui a été
repoussé décrit clairement une perte de
recettes pour un des départements les
moins riches de France donc vous
comprenez mon inquiétude en tant que
petit département très rural face à ce
que vous écrivez très bien et je connais
parfaitement ceux qui engrangent le plus
et ceux qui engrangent un peu mais moins
en proportion mais pour autant ce n'est
pas de faveur non plus à me rassurer
parfaitement donc
on peut partager ça il y a un contexte
de défiance
à une histoire récente assez finalement
ça fait un bout de la banque que le
département a été mis en
mouvement gestation en inquiétude avant
que finalement les grandes régions comme
le disait prise en charpinnes viennent
un peu faire atterrir tout ça quoi
conseiller territorial sur des grandes
régions c'est parce que ça veut dire
donc on parlait tout le temps mais ça
c'est plus jouable parce que même pour
ceux qui auraient pu le porter un
certain moment ça n'existe plus c'est
plus réalisable donc à partir de là les
départements sont plutôt confortés
aujourd'hui et donc à un moment donné il
faudra que les départements quittent le
terrain de la crainte pour aller sur le
terrain de la confiance
bien on terminera comme ça c'est très
beau magnifique bonne soirée à tous
merci merci beaucoup